Democrats double down on their screechy
rhetoric Google is trying to usher in an
era of civility and the Saudis are in
hot water I'm Ben Shapiro this is the
Ben Shapiro show here we are live from
Memphis yesterday I took my young deputy
Colton over to Graceland and we visited
with with Elvis and communed with the
King so that was kind of fun and then
wasn't spoke at University of Memphis so
that was a blast last night terrific
crowd thousand people showed up some
people in the overflow room it was
really just an awesome experience
we're gonna get to all the news of the
day in just one second but first let me
tell you would you like to be dressed
like a stud fellows I mean do you want
to dress like a killer well the way to
do that is to check it out over at Indo
Chino they're the world's most exciting
made-to-measure men's wear a company
they make suits and shirts to your exact
measurements for an unparalleled fit and
comfort guys love the wide selection of
high quality fabrics and colors to
choose from the option to personalize
the details including lapel lining
pockets buttons you can write your own
monogram if you go into one of their
showrooms then they will do all this
stuff for you and you actually get to
pick the the cloth out you get to pick
the look it's really fun and you do feel
like James Bond or you can just go to
their site at Indo Chino comm choose
your fabric inside and out to choose
those design customizations and then
relax well everything gets
professionally tailored and then sent to
you chinos originated 120 years ago as
part of a British French military
uniform
they're designed to be simple durable
comfortable in camouflage and earthy
tones well fast forward to recent times
this fashion classic has changed very
little until now because Indo chinos are
tailored for the perfect fit and
customizable to suit any personal taste
and style this week my listeners get any
premium into Indo Chino suit for just
359 bucks at Indo Chino comm when you
enter Shapiro at checkout again that's
Indo Chino dot-com for any premium Indo
Chino suit just three hundred fifty nine
dollars
Indo chinos an introductory price of 79
bucks in the United States also that'd
be their special Chino so go check those
out as well shipping is free Indo Chino
comm promo code Shapiro for any premium
suit for just 359 bucks and free
shipping once you custom once you go
custom you don't go rack its punny and
also awesome go check it out right now
okay so the Democrats are doubling down
on their commitment
incivility this should not be a shock to
anyone it really should not and I'm kind
of surprised frankly that so many
members of the media are pushing back
against the idea the Democrats embrace
anger and mob centric politics so Eric
Holder the Attorney General the
execrable attorney general he's the only
person who earns an execrable rating
from me outside of Michael moles is in
fact Eric Holder Eric Holder who's a
terrible terrible Attorney General he
came out and he said that our old
strategy in the Democratic Party used to
go when they go low we go high well now
our strategy is when they go low we kick
them here is Eric Holder saying just
that it is time for us as Democrats to
be as tough as they are to be as
dedicated as they are to be as committed
as they are Michelle always says
Michelle Byrom I love her you know
she my wife like really tight which
scares me abrupt Michelle which says you
know when they go low no they go low we
kick and Eric Holder knows of what she
speaks considering how he used the
office of the Attorney General to
protect his wingman Barack Obama yeah
there are a lot of folks are very upset
at Eric Holder today for saying this and
yes it's violent rhetoric
he then clarified that he didn't mean
that literally obviously but this is the
sort of rhetoric that Democrats have
been using for quite a while and it
turns out that a lot of Democrats do
mean this stuff literally so for example
there's his woman who wrote a piece for
The Huffington Post
her name is nine econo and she's very
excited because she went and screamed at
Mitch McConnell here's some tape of her
screaming at Senate Majority Leader
Mitch McConnell these women who are
talking to you about their surviving
story
why are you but to be meeting the
persons walking to keep me Jenna
McConnell is Willie telling you that she
shook the hand of a man while a woman is
shy at supper story Senator Carlos you
always turn your back on living like
this especially women of color who are
all sexual assualt of my favorite part
of that is where she says that all women
of color are sexual assault victims
which is pretty amazing I mean not like
really all of them I mean as some of
them I'm sure but but all of them it's
pretty amazing statement
she wrote a piece for The Huffington
Post called I confronted Mitch McConnell
and interrupted Susan Collins and I'll
do it again she says I am the executive
director of positive women's network
because she seems very positive a
national network of women in transgender
people living with HIV but you may know
me as one of those people who followed
McConnell through Washington DC's
National Airport last week as seen in a
tweet that quickly went viral I and
others like me confronted McConnell and
other politicians in airports and
offices and elevators earlier this month
because they refused to meet with the
people whom they allegedly represent
what happened at the airport that
afternoon is only one part of the story
and she talks about how she's harassed
Susan Collins and screamed at Susan
Collins during her speech affirmative
affirming her vote for Kavanagh she says
I will do it all again whenever and
wherever I am needed and I'm not alone
says there are tens of millions of us
with a lot of skin in the judicial game
women people of color LGBTQ individuals
people with disabilities and chronic
health conditions the Supreme Court has
the power to interpret uphold and
enforce laws in ways that ensure our
democratic and human rights or it can
entrench privilege and power for the
already privileged and powerful we in
all our diversity and rage are the
future and then she suggests that this
is how she wants things to go from now
on she says we will keep screaming we
will continue to confront our elected
officials wherever we encounter them we
will not be dissuaded by the police or
fines or jail time we are survivors not
just of sexual violence but of an entire
system that was designed to keep us in
our place so it's gonna be a lot of
screaming from here all the way to the
end my favorite part of this continues
to be the media gaslighting everybody no
no no these aren't mobs these folks are
members of mobs there's angry people you
know like angry people in groups
screaming at people and doing stuff
which normally we would call like a mob
but they're not a mob because they're
Democrats and this is what the media do
when I'm gonna say it when it's a I'm
gonna say Democratic mob it's not a mob
it's a group of angry people when it's a
Republican group of politically
concerned people not even doing anything
remotely violent then it's a mob here is
Don Lemon doing his damnedest to ensure
that people don't hear the truth about
what Democrats are doing in the public
square the real mob is a mob of white
supremacists who killed a woman in
Charlottesville killed killed people who
are voicing their opinion about
something that they don't believe in or
that's they think is bad for them is how
the government how the country works
that's not a mob well I love that the
only standard for mob is they killed
someone now there's never been a mob
outside of mobs that kill somebody and
by the way it's important to note that
in Charlottesville the person who killed
somebody did so when he got in his car
and drove away from his own mob and then
went and rammed into somebody so wasn't
like the mob went crazy ran over a bunch
of gates and then started destroying
people they did that but that didn't
result in the death so even by his own
logical standard it doesn't make sense
Charlottesville was a mob that's the
point but it's not the only mob and yet
folks on CNN are very very strong in
their belief that the only sort of mob
that's real is right-wing mobs Maxine
Waters also trotting out this talking
point Maxine Waters the same woman who
said in front of a crowd that people
should confront and get in the face of
people at gas stations and restaurants
and they should harass folks in public
places now she says well the only real
type of mob is mob that has to do with
President Trump that's the only real
kind of mob they're trying to change the
description of protests and call it a
mob
well this president is the poster boy
for what a mob protester looks like okay
so from is the definition of a poster
boy for a mob but you're changing the
definition of a mob in order to actual
label actually label mobs mobs make
perfect sense to me Senator Mike Lee
he's a friend of mine and also I think a
very solid citizen and he came out and
he said listen we got he got doxxed last
week there are meaning
there was a staffer for a Democrat who
revealed his personal information he
says that sort of unsafe that seems sort
of like a mob tactic maybe it's terrible
it leaves us feeling very unsafe
like my wife is had to be followed to
the park by the local police they're not
a pleasant thing Hey the the fact that
the Democrats are now suggesting they're
not involved in these sorts of mob
tactics is really kind of astonishing
especially because there's a long
history of Democrats using the mobs as
political tools see there is this
strategy it's called a Fred Segal who's
an author of a great book called the
future was once here about major
American cities destroyed by Democratic
liberalism he calls it riot ideology a
riot ideology according to Fred Segal is
this belief that riots are a reflection
of deep underlying social ills that can
only be cured by more government and
what you would see from the Democrats is
an attempt to actually forward mob
politics to forward the mob to feed the
braying mob to make the mob larger to
encourage riots and then turn around Hey
look at this this riot is happening
because the people are angry the only
way to cure this is to give the people
what they want
aka more government or dollars or
something else this is a tactic of the
Democrats it has been an actual tactic
of Democrats for generations Marion
Barry who ended up being mayor of
Washington DC he said regarding the
Black Panthers who are a violent actual
terrorist group says I know for a fact
that white people get scared of the
Panthers and they might look at somebody
a little bit more moderate and say well
let's give them money and said there he
is supporting them up New York Mayor
John Lindsay who is a very very liberal
Republican he said that mass unrest
could be the spur to more leftist
policies he said quote our experiences
that some good can come of confrontation
politics you remember when the left
fully embraced the Occupy Wall Street
movement despite their crime and
violence despite the fact that they were
occupying public places and turning them
into pigsty Jay Carney the White House
press secretary under Obama said of
Occupy Wall Street quote one man's mob
is another man's democracy you remember
when Barack Obama expressed sympathy for
rioters in cities ranging from Baltimore
to Ferguson he said this about the
situation in Ferguson he said those who
are only interested in focusing on the
violence
and just want the problem to go away
need to recognize that we have work to
do here and we shouldn't try to paper it
over whenever we do that the anger may
momentarily subside but over time it
builds up and America isn't everything
that it could be in other words riots
are always an expression of public anger
so long as the public anger moves us in
the direction of more government
liberalism in fact Barack Obama was not
afraid to use the mob as a catalyst for
his policy preferences basically
throughout his entire career right after
the 2008 financial crisis President
Obama takes office he's a big meeting
when a bunch of bank CEOs and at that
meeting he turns to them and he says you
basically ought to cave to my entire
agenda because if you don't I will let
the mob get you this is a direct quote
from Barack Obama reported by a
political quote my administration is the
only thing between you and the
pitchforks that is demagoguery sure
demagoguery and of course when it comes
to sort of this casually violent
language President Obama is no exception
he's used this language too it was Jim
Messina his White House deputy chief of
staff who said the Democrats should
punch back twice as hard
it was Barack Obama who said if they
bring a knife to the fight we bring a
gun and told people to get in their face
and as Barack Obama saying that so all
the talk about Trump is unique in
American politics because of the way he
talks and that's what's causing all of
us just not true you have to be
historically ignorant to think this and
it has been a long-standing part of the
Democratic agenda to use mobs in order
to achieve political purposes I'll
explain more in just a second but first
let's talk about your comfort your
comfort down below okay dudes
close your eyes well unless you are
driving right now imagine yourself in
your current underwear would you be
proud of your underwear choice today if
the driver in front or behind you saw it
first of all I don't know why you'd have
your butt out the window but if you did
and the other drivers saw what was on it
would you be proud of your underwear
choice if the answer is no you need to
talk to my to the friends over at Tommy
John Tommy John is the clothing brand
that is redefining comfort for men and
women they obsess over every little
detail and stitch these fabrics that
perform like nothing you've ever worn
before Tommy John's men's and women's
underwear Sport a no wedgie guarantee
which would have been super helpful for
me in high school
comfortable stay put waist bands and a
range of fabrics that are luxuriously
soft feather-light moisture wicking
breathable and designed to move with you
not against you Tommy John is so
confident in their underwear and if you
don't love your first pair
can get a full refund with their best
pair you'll ever wear or it's free
guarantee all of that includes their
life changing women's underwear which is
now fully back in stock so before you
spend another dime on cheap
heat-trapping multi pack underwear
check out Tommy John no adjustment
needed go to Tommy John comm slash
appear oh now save 20% on your first
order that's Tommy John comm slash
apparel for 20% off again Tommy John
comm slash Shapiro's so back to this
Democratic mob politics routine I'm very
familiar with this because they've been
doing this on college campuses they
basically incentivize violence on
college campuses by saying that if
things get too violent well then we'll
just BAM conservatives very convenient
and as my there's violence over at
Berkley and so the administration will
say well we've got a band conservative
speakers until we can get a hold of the
situation which is basically the rioters
veto we experienced this at DePaul
University last year when students
suggested that they might get riotous
and violent over me visiting campus and
so DePaul simply banned me and then they
threatened to arrest me if I showed up
there's tape of me standing in front of
a security guy there head of security
there who's telling me that if I take
one step forward he will arrest me and
it's truly amazing stuff
Democrats have engaged in this sort of
stuff for a very long time and it's
always rich to hear what they're willing
to label a mob folks on the Left were
perfectly willing to label not only
Trump supporters a mob but go back a few
years before that I'm old enough to
remember the Tea Party which was in
large part a bunch of people standing
around carrying don't tread on me flags
and reading the Declaration of
Independence at rallies I went to a
bunch of Tea Party events I spoke at a
bunch of Tea Party events I was a
charter member of the Tea Party the left
called them mobs the left said that the
tea partiers were mobs they said occupy
which was involved in actual criminal
activity many many many literally dozens
and dozens maybe hundreds of arrests
across the country of Occupy protesters
that was not a mob but the Tea Party was
mob the Tea Party was really a mob Jimmy
Hoffa jr. I remember there's some events
in 2011 I remember him introducing
President Obama there and suggesting
that the tea party were quote sons of
and he said well let's take
these sons of out right because
they were a mob for Democrats any form
of Republican speech is demagoguery and
being a mob anytime you get more than
two Republicans in an area together its
mob but Democrats who are actually
charging the steps of the Supreme Court
and bashing on the 13-ton doors and
chanting stop Brett Kavanaugh those
people are not a mob people who are
running through the Senate heart
building trying to buttonhole senators
in elevators without security protocol
those people are not a mob it's not a
mob when folks go to Washington DC find
conservatives and then rip up their
signs that's not a mob it's not a mob
when you have Occupy Wall Street
occupying large swaths of land into
Fayette the filing into facing it not a
mob the only mob is Charlotte Schultz
the only mob we've ever seen and we keep
hearing this from the media it is the
only mob the only mob is the mob in
Charlottesville that of course is not
true it's silly and more than that it is
obviously politically motivated in the
media are part of this whole routine so
the the left is is making the case that
their politics is not the politics of
the mob
instead anybody who's angry at the
politics of the mob anybody who's angry
at the attempts you get Brett Kavanaugh
for example the mob justice
that was attempted I'm Brett Kavanaugh
and it was mob justice there's no due
process he was just going to have his
life ended essentially by a bunch of
people screaming the folks on the Left
have decided that any resistance to that
is just because you are a privileged
white person Charles blow who's aptly
named over at the New York Times he has
a column today called white male
victimization anxiety and here is what
he says he says during the swearing-in
of justice Brett Kavanaugh on Monday
Donald Trump took it upon himself to
apologize to Cavanaugh and his family on
behalf of our nation for the terrible
pain and suffering you've been forced to
endure he repeated the tire lines that
he and Republicans hope will stick and
steer the comatose base to electoral
fervor that accusations of sexual
assault against Cavanaugh were part of a
campaign of political and personal
destruction based on lies and deception
they were and what happens who the
Cavanaugh family violates every notion
of fairness decency and due process it
did but here's Charles blows perspective
to me this was not just a president and
party worried about an approaching blue
wave and trying to take political
advantage of a moment of victory it was
an outright and increasing amplification
of a reactionary white male
victimization syndrome that is consumed
modern American conservative
Vox has called it the unleashing of
white male backlash this is very bad by
the way white males are not allowed to
defend their rights if they do this is
just evidence that they are privileged
so if white males are given due process
then that shows that they are privileged
and if they are not given due process
and then they get angry that also shows
that they are privileged so just like
every other major leftist argument these
days the conclusion is already assumed
it's just a question of how you get
there
according to Charles blow the women
accusing the white man of assault
weren't the victims instead the white
man was the victim well to be accurate
the actual accusation is that the women
accusing the white man of assault didn't
have any collaborative evidence which
means that you are trying to get this
guy without any corroborate of evidence
whatsoever in some people's eyes as
below he was the victim of political
correctness meets whose overreach a
check your white male privilege culture
drunk on its own self-righteousness
which is all of which is true because
that's what happened but that's not
really what this is about
according to Charles blow Cavanaugh's
belligerent offense and Trump's
dismissal of the accusers he mocked
wanted a political rally and called the
accusations a hoax
you'll recall that some folks like me
criticized that and said that he
shouldn't have mocked Christine bladesey
for because he didn't know the facts
either but according to blow they
represent for many men a back against
the wall no more space for a treet
moment of fighting back of pushing back
of standing proud in their patriarchy
and proclaiming that it will not bend
now due process is patriarchy now
presumption of innocence is patriarchy
blow continues they're saying enough
they will cede no more ground they will
share no more power they'll accommodate
no more ascendancy and validation of the
oppressed now he might want to add the
word allegedly oppressed there because
again none of those allegations have
actually been supported by any evidence
he says that is what they're telling us
and they are speaking through Trump he
says the victim sensibility Trump is
articulating is not generationally
restricted in January a PRI MTV poll of
15 to 24 year olds found that 43 percent
of young white men say discrimination
against whites is as serious a problem
as discrimination against other groups
29 percent of young white women agreed
with them and nearly half believe
efforts to increase diversity will harm
white people because by nature the
definition of the left's attempts to
increase diversity include
harming white people meaning what the
left wants from diversity is not
ideological diversity or diversity of
experience what the left says is that we
should give slots that belong to
qualified white people to unqualified
non-white people this is an actual point
that the left believes in I don't even
know how the left can argue this
particular logic it doesn't make any
sense if you are saying that there is a
group of college admin T's of which too
many are white and we need to replace
some of those white people with
non-white people how does that not harm
white people you're gonna have to
explain that one and as for the notion
that discrimination against whites is as
serious a problem as discrimination
against other groups there are two ways
to read that question and I think that
there's one accurate way in one
inaccurate way the inaccurate way is to
say that historically and presently
discrimination against black folks is
just is is not as bad as discrimination
against white folks with which I
disagree and then there's the way to
read it which is that as a whole the
left is interested in stomping white
dudes because they think that there is a
patriarchy that must be punished and
that patriarchy has to do with the color
of your skin and therefore if you are
white you don't get to process that
part's true that part's true
well we'll conclude Charles blows
account in just a second and we'll show
why this is going to generate a backlash
why this is actually bad politics on the
part of the Democrats in one second but
first let's talk about the window
coverings in your home and office now I
know you didn't think about that that
much right you've redecorated your house
we've done nothing about the window
coverings and then you wonder why is my
house looking a little shabby
that's because window coverings do make
a very large difference when the window
coverings in your house look better
they're great but if not everything in
the house looks cheap and that's why you
need to go check out blinds com they
make it really easy for you if you're
not sure what you want even where to
start with blinds calm you get a free
online design consultation you send them
pictures of your house and they will
send back custom recommendations from a
professional for what will work with
your color scheme furniture in specific
rooms they'll even send you free samples
to make sure everything looks as good in
person as it does online and every order
gets free shipping and here's the best
part if you accidentally mismeasure are
you picked the wrong color
it's your screw-up lines com will remake
your blinds for free which is a pretty
awesome deal for a limited time get 20%
off everything at blinds comm when you
use promo code Ben
that's blinds.com promo code Ben for 20%
off everything faux wood blinds cellular
shades roller shades the whole deal
blinds.com promo code Ben rules and
restrictions do apply go check them out
right now ok so concluding Charles blows
column in the New York Times in which he
accuses white males of a sense of
victimization he says he says that NPR's
Dominique Oman Montanaro pointed out in
August that since Trump announced he was
running for president he has used the
word an unfair 69 times and tweets and
since becoming president 40 times and
then he says Trump's sense of fairness
her unfairness really has driven him his
rise in politics and his priorities for
the country has capitalized on grievance
especially that of white Americans
chafing at the culture of a
demographically changing country and has
expressed his view of what is unfair
everything from trade and immigration to
the court system now on this show I have
said that I don't like victimization
culture I don't like it from white folks
and I like it from black folks I don't
like the idea that you believe that you
are a victim in a free society with that
said the left has been saying for years
on end the day of the white man is over
the day of whites in this country is
over demographic shifts are going to
completely change the way the culture is
done and white men it's time for you to
sit down and shut up that is a form of
discrimination if you actually want to
make an argument in favor of a cultural
shift in America make the argument in
favor of the cultural shift but don't do
it predicated on the color of the people
that you're talking about that's what
the left has done and it's driving an
awful lot of backlash and I think to a
certain extent appropriate backlash if
you say to a group of people you no
longer matter in American life what do
you think they're going to do what do
you think they're going to do so Charles
blow concludes through it all Trump's
mantra and mission remained clear to
bind together toxic masculinity and
racial performance anxiety into a weapon
that can repel change and any perceived
to minutia of white male primacy Trump
is on a campaign to make America's white
men feel great again well maybe
president Trump is on a mission to point
out that discriminatory politics in any
form is bad or if he's not he should be
if he's not he certainly should be I
mean that is a really biased take on
what's going on in American politics
that Trump wants to bind together toxic
masculinity and racial performance
anxiety the suggestion being
that the only people who are angry right
now the only people who are upset with
the left our toxic males want to rape
people and whites who are
underperforming nonsense nonsense I am
angry at lack of due process and I am
bout as feminist at as it is possible to
be with regard to what women should be
allowed to do in the United States they
should have every right that men have
and I've said that 1 million times on
this program it would be very difficult
to label me toxically masculine and as
for racial performance anxiety this idea
that what I'm really upset about is that
white people are underperforming I don't
really have that that's not a thing ok
then I'm not concerned about the color
of people who are underperforming
and I certainly am not one of the these
folks who is supposedly underperforming
generally it would be hard to make that
case as well I am angry however and I'm
angry at a left which seeks to divide us
based on color and then the minute that
you say listen stop dividing us based on
color the left says oh that's because
you're a patriarchal discriminatory
white man that's the logic being used
right now now this will backlash this
will backlash and the backlash is not
just going to come from white folks the
great lie of the left is that political
correctness has been embraced by all
minorities and political correctness is
only opposed by the white majority
that's alive left well there is a new
study out from yasha monkeys a lecture
on government at Harvard University and
here's what he finds he says that
Americans across cultural and ethnic
lines don't like PC culture it annoys
them they are sick of the left trying to
shut down debate by simply shouting that
you are of a particular color here's
what he writes at the Atlantic it's a
fascinating article on social media the
country seems to divide into two neat
camps call them the woke and the
resentful team resentment his man pun
very much intended by people who are
predominantly old and exclusively white
team woke is young likely to be female
and predominantly black brown or Asian
the white allies do their dutiful part
these teams are roughly equal in number
and they disagree most vehemently as
well as most routinely about the
catch-all known as political correctness
reality is nothing like this says yasha
monk over at the Atlantic as scholar
Steven Hawkins Daniel Yadkin Marion want
auras and Tim Dickson argue in a report
published Wednesday hidden tribes study
of America's polarized landscape most
American
don't fit into either of these camps
they also share a more common ground
than the daily fights on social media
might suggest including a general
aversion to PC culture the study was
written by more uncommon an organization
founded in memory of Joe Cox who's a
British MP murdered in the run-up to the
breakfast referendum it was based on
nationally representative pull of eight
thousand respondents between December
2017 and September 2018 and here is what
they find according to the report 25% of
Americans are traditional or devoted
conservatives and their views are far
outside the American mainstream some
eight percent of Americans are
progressive activists and their views
are even less typical by contrast
two-thirds of Americans who don't belong
to either extreme constitute an
exhausted majority and that would be
most of us I'm a traditional devoted
conservative but I think I would also
probably be a member of the exhausted
majority their members share a sense of
fatigue with our polarized national
conversation a willingness to be
flexible in their political viewpoints
and a lack of voice in the national
conversation most members of the
exhausted majority and then some dislike
political correctness among the general
population a full 80% 80% believe
political correctness is a problem in
our country young people don't like
political correctness 74% between 24 and
29 79 percent under age 24 the woke are
in a clear minority across all ages race
is also a bad proxy whites are less
likely than average to believe political
correctness is a problem less likely 82%
of Asians think political correctness is
a problem 87% of Hispanics think
political correctness is a problem 88%
of American Indians think political
correctness is a problem I love this 140
year old American Indian in Oklahoma
said this quote it seems like every day
you wake up something has changed you
say Jew or Jewish is a black guy
african-american you're on your toes
because you never know what to say so
political correctness in that sense is
scary the only part of the stands are
narrative that the day shift data
partially affirmed is that black folks
in the United States are more likely to
support political correctness but
three-quarters of blacks still oppose
political correctness so it turns out
the vast majority of Americans in every
racial category are in
annoyed by the whoa crowd and their
insistence that nobody ever be offended
so Charles blows take which is that we
are allowed to racially polarized so
long as we are targeting one political
group that's not popular that's not
popular eighty-three percent of
respondents who make less than fifty
grand just like political correctness
just seventy percent of those who make
more than a hundred Rand are skeptical
about it okay so that means that the
richer you get the more you like
political correctness so it's not poor
people pushing political correctness
inside minorities pushing political
correctness it is disproportionately
rich white people pushing political
correctness that's amazing now there is
a political gap here among conservatives
ninety-seven percent believe political
correctness is a problem among
traditional liberal sixty one percent to
the only ones who really really really
like the woke culture are progressive
activists only 30 percent see political
correctness is a problem they are far
far outside of the mainstream so who's
in this group according to the Atlantic
I love this compared with the rest of
the polling sample progressive activists
are much more likely to be rich highly
educated and white they're nearly twice
as likely as the average to make more
than a hundred grand a year they're
nearly three times as likely to have a
post-grad degree and while 12% of the
overall sample in the study is
african-american only 3% of progressive
activists are its rich white kids rich
white kids those are the people who are
creating a lot of the problems in our
society right now with their talk of
divisive polarization and political
correctness in one second I'm gonna
explain what the study means by
political correctness is that sort of
important we have to define our terms
I'll get to that in just one second but
first let's talk about your sleep
quality so why would you get a mattress
made for anyone else right why not have
a personalized mattress we live in a
personalized society where you can order
anything the way you want it why not get
your mattress the way you wanted to
helix sleep can make that happen for you
and they built a sleep quiz it takes two
minutes to complete they use the answers
to match your body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress
whether you're a side sleeper or a hot
sleeper whether you're like a plush or a
firm bed helix can make it happen for
you all you have to do is go to helix
sleep calm slash man you take there two
minutes sleep quiz and they will match
you to a mattress that will give you the
best sleep of your life you look silly
mattresses are awesome my wife and I
have
we like to our so much that we actually
got my sister one for her wedding as
well for couples Helix can even split
the mattress down the middle providing
individual support needs and feel
preferences for each side they have a
10-year warranty and you get to try it
out for 100 nights risk-free so you have
nothing to lose right now helix is
offering up to 125 bucks off all
mattress orders get up to 125 bucks off
at helix sleep comm / Ben that's helix
sleep comm / Ben for 125 dollars off
your mattress order again helix sleep
comm / Ben let them use that / Ben's
that they know that we sent you he's in
just a second oh and get back into the
study plus a big scandal over at Google
broken by Breitbart we'll talk about
that first you have to go and subscribe
for $9.99 a month get the rest of the
show live the rest of the Andrew Clavin
show live the rest of Michael Moses show
live yet all of those wonderful glories
plus you can get the leftist Cheers hot
or cold tumbler which I have once again
forgotten to bring with me today to show
to you but if you've seen the show
before then you know what I am talking
about it might be around not here in any
case be leftist ears Hydra cold tumbler
is the finest of all beverage vessels so
go check that out for $99 a year also
when you do that you get access to
another Kingdom season 2 which comes
along with the visuals you get early
episodes it's really fun it's really a
kick it's written by Andrew Clavin and
read by Michael moles the only thing of
Michael Moses I will ever recommend so
go check that out right now also
subscribe so you can see our Sunday
conversations right you can know you can
see our Sunday specials that we do with
big names from all across the political
spectrum subscribe at YouTube or iTunes
leave us or a five-star review over
there only 5 stars
we do not accept 4 star reviews the app
will automatically reject it if you give
a four star review only 5 star reviews
are allowed so go check that out right
now we're the largest fastest-growing
conservative podcast in the nation
[Music]
so Americans hate hate hate hate hate
political correctness but what do they
mean by political correctness according
to the Atlantic in extended interviews
and focus groups participants made clear
they were concerned about their
day-to-day ability to express themselves
they worried that a lack of familiarity
with a topic or an unthinking word
choice could lead to serious social
sanctions for them so they're not really
sure what it means but they know that
they don't like the feeling of
restriction that the woke left has
created but there's plenty of support
for the idea that Americans are not as
neatly divided by age or race as is
commonly believed according to Pew only
26 percent of black Americans consider
themselves liberal nearly half of
Latinos argue that many people nowadays
are too sensitive to how Muslims are
treated - and five black folks say that
an immigration nowadays is bad for
America in other words this notion that
demographics is destiny which has been
pushed by both sides of the political
aisle to a certain extent is just not
true hey there is no shrinking white
majority that is going to inevitably
lead to liberal domination and there is
no inevitably increasing liberal
majority that is going to lead to
incredible victory over time people's
minds can be changed in other words we
are individuals we are not just members
of groups that's really important to
remember in the middle of what is a very
very polarized news cycle and this is
why the left has some serious problems
even going forward now that doesn't mean
that the right can't do things to
alienate folks the right obviously can
do things to alienate folks and I would
say there's a difference between being
politically incorrect and being a jerk
and this is where the right has to be
careful not everything that you say that
is offensive is just you being
politically incorrect sometimes it's you
being a jerk if you use the n-word
that's not you being politically
incorrect it is you being a jerk if you
say that men and women are different
that is politically incorrect and you
would not being a jerk what I would
recommend is that if you actually want
to side with that middle of America that
is tired of the standards that are being
pervade by the left be polite be civil
and be politically incorrect say things
that are factual specifically because
they are factual and not merely to
offend believe me you don't have to
purposely offend the left the left will
be offended anyway none of it matters
hey the left will always be offended I
just spoke at USC last week and it was
fascinating there's a young
black woman who got up to ask a question
and she said you've been accused of
inciting violence and I said well you've
been here the whole time have you heard
anything that you think would incite
violence and she thought about it for a
second and she said no of course not of
course not the reason that folks on the
Left suggest that I incite violence is
because they disagree with me
that is why well it turns out that most
Americans would rather have disagreement
than impute violence to somebody who's
not involved in violence and when the
left equates speech and violence and
then says that their own violence is
speech all they're doing is alienating
the vast majority of the American people
the left is now playing a game the
Democratic Party is playing a game the
speech of the right they say is violence
because right wingers are bad and their
own violence is speech so in the left
goes and pounds on the doors of the
Supreme Court and acts threatening
that's just a form of speech that's just
anger according to CNN but if folks on
the right say stuff that offends people
that's now a form of violence on CNN
Headline News when I say a man is a man
and a woman is a woman and some
transgender woman grips me by the back
of the neck and threatens me by bodily
harm those two things are equivalent me
saying a man as a man a woman as a woman
according to the left is the equivalent
of somebody grabbing me physically on
national television and threatening to
send me home in an ambulance which is
literally what happened and also makes
no sense because you don't go home in an
ambulance the left is engaged in in this
really polarizing game and most
Americans don't buy in that's what we
found out in the trumpet and in the
Trump era most Americans don't buy in
now that doesn't mean that Trump's gonna
win from here to eternity it doesn't
mean that Republicans always win
Republicans are not good at this game
they're not and again when you mistake
political and correctness for being a
jerk or vice versa you are making a
rather large mistake yourself but it is
important to note that this notion on
the left that the woke majority is just
all the black people and all the women
and everybody else it's just not true
statistically and that's a very very
important thing to keep in mind we still
have more in common than then not and
you could be fooled by watching our
politics or watching social media I get
fooled too but it's not reality it's not
reality okay speaking of folks who are
not living in reality there is a leaked
report from Google it was leaked to
Breitbart and it's just in a
amazing report so Breitbart reports an
internal company briefing produced by
Google and Lietz exclusively to
Breitbart news argues that due to a
variety of factors including the
election of President Trump the American
tradition of free speech on the Internet
is no longer viable
this goes to exactly what I'm saying
folks on the Left have decided that if
there's speech they don't like it is
equivalent to violence and thus it must
be shut down
despite leaks video footage showing top
executives declaring their intention to
ensure that the rise of Trump and the
populist movement is just a blip in its
history Google has repeatedly denied
that the political bias of its employees
filters into its product but the 85 page
briefing titled the good sensor the
goods I mean how Orwellian is that right
they actually have a briefing at Google
called the good sensor great job guys
admits that Google and other tech
platforms now quote control the majority
of online conversations and have
undertaken a shift towards censorship in
response to unwelcome political events
around the world in a second I'm going
to go through this report and explain to
you why this is so bad plus I want to
talk a little bit about this horrific
situation with the Saudi government
allegedly murdering a Saudi dissident at
the Embassy in Turkey and what the Trump
administration should do about it so
what's in this Google report well here's
what it says first it says in the report
that users are asking if the openness of
the Internet should be celebrated after
all and they say that free speech has
become a social economic and political
weapon if you are Google and you say
political speech is a weapon I would
suggest you don't understand what free
speech is they say that the early free
speech ideals of the internet were
utopian they even point out that maybe
they shouldn't be considered a platform
anymore I've said this on the program
before platforms
it's like AT&T right you pick up a phone
you can say what you want on the phone
line and the AT&T doesn't shut down the
conversation based on what you say that
makes it a platform if AT&T were to be
like The Daily wire then they would
actually be a publisher right they could
decide what is and is not published if
that's the case then they have all sorts
of legal liabilities you don't have as a
platform Google is essentially admitting
they might in fact be a publisher not a
platform the briefing from Google
identify several factors that allegedly
eroded faith in free speech the election
of Donald Trump and the alleged Russian
involved
is identified as one such factor so
basically Democrats brow big brow beated
Google into believing that they are
responsible through allowing free speech
into Donald Trump being president and
then they talk about the rise of online
hate speech and then they also talk
about spreading conspiracy theories but
the most important thing appears on
pages 66 through 68 their briefing
argues that Google Facebook YouTube and
Twitter are caught between two
incompatible positions first the unmet
and the unmediated marketplace of ideas
right that would be the free speech
tradition of the United States and
second the well-ordered spaces for
safety and civility which would be the
publisher space right this would be them
determining what sort of conversations
we ought to have they say that the
American tradition prioritizes free
speech for democracy not civility the
second tradition is described as the
European tradition which favors dignity
over Liberty and civility over freedom
and then the briefing concludes all tech
platforms are now moving toward the
European tradition that's scary stuff
that's very scary stuff and that is
political correctness come to life that
is all your social media companies
siding with the woke left that most
Americans don't like saying we should
shut down ideas we should redirect
people's eyeballs
we should move people toward a civility
that we want and we will define civility
civility may not include your viewpoint
this is dangerous dangerous stuff and
it's one of the reasons why we should
all be very wary of these massive social
media companies that seem to be
targeting specific political points of
view now I do want to talk a little bit
about the situation with regard to Jamal
Khashoggi he is a columnist or was a
columnist for The Washington Post he's
been missing since entering the Saudi
consulate in Istanbul last week the
Turkish police alleged that he went into
the consulate and that he was then
murdered by these by members of the
Saudi consulate that basically the
Saudis brought in 15 people a kill squad
to go into the consulate kill this guy
dismember him and then bury him the
Saudi government is still denying foul
play the Turkish government has provided
specifics and evidence there's video of
khashoggi entering the consulate and
they've provided the names of 15 saudi
agents that it says flew to Istanbul in
pursuit of him the Saudis have issued
blanket denials but this is raising some
very serious issues for the United
States because the United the Trump
administration has been very close to
Crown Prince Mohammed bin Salman and
that's because Solomon has been treated
as a reformer he's somebody who
supposedly wants to move away from some
of the fundamentalism of Saudi Arabia
he's been involved in the creation of an
anti Iranian alliance in the Middle East
the United States has heavily funded the
Saudi government in their fight in Yemen
because the Saudis are basically having
a proxy war with Iran in Yemen and so
this has raised questions because
Khashoggi was a legal resident of the
United States this has raised questions
about whether the United States ought to
punish the Saudis by withdrawing support
for their for their arms we should stop
selling them weaponry for example the
reason that this is a dicey issue is not
because we should keep providing them
arms on a moral level the reason it's a
dicey issue is because there is another
party at the table and that is the
Iranian government which is an actual
terrorist government and the Turkish
government is much more warm with the
Iranians than they are with the Saudis
the Turkish government right now is
holding a US pastor in prison so none of
these regimes are great but it does
provide the Trump administration with a
choice choice number one is basically
slap the Saudis on the wrist pretend
that nothing bad happened choice number
two is to basically downgrade the Saudi
relationship with the United States over
all of this to suggest that the choice
doesn't have ramifications or that it's
easy is to miss read the nature of
global politics my tendency is to say
that if this happened you have to
downgrade the Saudis there's just no way
around it you have to withdraw armed
support for the Saudis and they have to
be punished because this cannot be
allowed to go on by an American ally we
should also remember that their
geopolitical considerations at play and
backing the Iranians in order to stop
the Saudis or allowing the Iranians to
run roughshod through the Middle East
because the Saudis did something evil
here would not be a good outcome either
sometimes there is no good outcome and
it's just awful the Saudis put the
United States in this position
geopolitically and also obviously a lot
more awful that it sounds like they
murdered a guy because he was a
dissident at their consulate in Istanbul
it's just just terrible just terrible
okay so as we continue we'll talk a
little bit more about that and we'll get
to some things I like in things I hate
so president Trump has sounded off on
this yesterday he came out he said
listen we can't let this happen like
this can't be a thing
this is a bad situation we cannot let
this happen to reporters to anybody we
can't let this happen and we're gonna
get to the bottom of it okay okay so
obviously Trump very unhappy about this
Lindsey Graham who's been a big Trump
ally
he says there'll be hell to pay if this
guy actually was murdered I've never
been more disturbed than them right now
if this did in fact happen if this man
was murdered in the Saudi consulate in
Istanbul that were crossed every line of
normality in the international community
if it did happen they would be held to
pay
okay now let's point out that would
anybody be that surprised I mean the
Saudi Arabian government has been a
dictatorship a rather evil dictatorship
for several generations now so I don't
think anybody would be supremely
surprised if it turns out that this is
what happened but it will necessitate
action on the part of the United States
and as I say that action could take one
of two forms Eli Lake has a good piece
over at Bloomberg talking about all of
this
he says there's a deeper problem with
the slap on the wrist and let's the
Saudis believe the US needs them more
than they need us it effectively puts
the Saudis in control of the alliance
and what about the more severe
responsible Saudi Arabia would
definitely get the message and other US
allies would understand their
consequences if America were called its
top diplomat and supported a UN
resolution but that risks undermining
Prince Mohammed bin Salman and the
alternatives in Saudi Arabia aren't much
better the US has an interest in his
success what's more less US military
engagement in Yemen could actually lead
to more civilian casualties so we will
find out what happens here my guess in
the end is that the United States does a
mixture that the United States punishes
the Saudis temporarily and then comes
back to them in three months and talks
about what they can do to rectify the
relationship that's the that's the
probable outcome but suffice it to say
that it's deeply disturbing and messed
up that the Saudi Arabian government
decided to put the United States in this
position aside from the innate evil of
killing a man who apparently was going
to a apparently was going to Semba sea
to get a marriage license just just
terrible stuff okay time for some things
I like and then some things that I hate
so things that I like I'll give a shout
out to encounter books encounter books
is a wonderful publisher they do
incredible work I've been a big fan of
the stuff that they do over at encounter
for a very very long
time they publish some of my favorite
authors people like Heather McDonald
published by encounter books just too
many authors over there to name they're
having their 20th anniversary gala this
weekend unfortunately I wasn't able to
go but if you are in New York you should
think about going it really should be a
kick and you know good for them and
counter does tremendous tremendous stuff
then I believe it's still Roger Kimball
over there they do just excellent
excellent work so if you go check out
all of their published works very
intellectual publications I really like
encounter okay other things that I like
so shout out to the producer of James
Bond Barbra broccoli who's the longtime
executive producer and the daughter of
the franchise creator albert broccoli
she says the James Bond will never be a
woman well good because um what the hell
why would James Bond ever be a woman
like in it wouldn't make any sense of
James Bond or a woman who's attracting
guys like the key to James Bond as a
character is that he is a rogue right
he's a rogue who attracts women now the
reason that that makes him unique is
because women and men do not treat sex
the same way you know this James Bond is
quote-unquote a player right it's a
player with a heart rate he always finds
a woman in one of these films a
beautiful woman and then she falls for
him and then they sleep together at
least one woman per film now you want to
know what you call a woman and get a guy
in bed a woman right that's what we call
that right hey hey the guys are not the
same bad sex as women so if you had a
beautiful woman and she liked you she
was able to get that guy in bed that is
not any sort of actual plot line because
there's no tension whatsoever in the
plot line I mentioned this study the
other night at University at Buffalo one
of my favorite social science studies
ever from 1989 there is it's I think
it's Clarke and Hadfield or the guys who
did this study and the study was they
took an attractive female and they had
her go to a bar and proposition a bunch
of guys want to come home with me at
night they had an attractive male go
into a bar and proposition a bunch of
females want to come home with me at
night
seventy-five percent of dudes
proposition by the female said yes zero
women said yes zero for people who think
that men and women are exactly the same
about matters sexual that is just
asinine
in fact turning James Bond into a woman
makes no sense at all and the way that
you can tell this is they tried to do
this with atomic blonde and it was a
box-office failure there is no
about atomic blonde and Charlize Theron
an atomic blonde where she couldn't have
been a dude like they could have
literally had a dude say every one of
those lines and do every one of those
actions and the movie would have worked
in almost exactly the same way nobody
actually wants to see a woman play James
Bond I'm sorry to break it to folks if
you want to create a new character who's
not James Bond and his female and is
written uniquely female go for it but
men and women are not interchangeable
on-screen or in real life okay time for
a couple of things that I hate so now I
have to tell you a story okay so my
produce my producer Colton who travels
with new and we are on the road young
Colton we are on the road and where we
were at we didn't event in Detroit it's
a great event and we're without our
security detail also now one of the it's
it's both tragic that I have to have a
security detail in order to go around
giving speeches but it's also fun in the
sense that I really like the guys on my
security detail they're all ex-military
and they're blast and they're really a
kick so we were so we go to this event
in Detroit great event at a church and
afterward there are a bunch of off-duty
police officers who are there who are
fans and one of them says okay I know
you need to get to the airport how about
we give you a police escort I said okay
sure sounds great so this this female
police officer jumps into her car and
we're cruising down the highway toward
the airport to get on her flight and
she's got her lights on and suddenly
behind us pulls up another cop and this
other cop pulls us over and we were like
okay so why are you pulling us over and
the first thing he says is because
you're following a police officer and we
were like well right because she's
guiding us to the airport and he says
really that's her it's just she's
guiding you to the airport
yes she's giving us an escort to the
airport and he says well your brights
were on like know our brights were not
on you're just making that up and then
because all the guys in my security
detail are ex-military one of them
starts to get out of the car to talk to
the police officer and police officers
getting real uptight and I'm gonna get
back in the car get back in the car
Michael diamond gets shot on the side of
the freeway by a bad cop with a stick up
his butt and well and here's the part
that's amazing this is the best part so
the police officer who was guiding us
there has now pulled over on the side of
the freeway as well and so we say to
this police officer why don't you go and
ask the person in that car
and he says well I don't know that's a
police officer and we say well that's a
police car and this officer says well
you know there are people on our force
who go home at night and you know they
build police cars and they just ride
around in them now number one that's not
a thing number two if that's happening
and you are posing as a police officer
that's a crime so if you actually think
that that is a person who has built a
formal police car and is driving around
with their lights on off-duty shouldn't
you go arrest the person doing that you
know ten feet in front of us and not
bother us eventually this police officer
goes and actually asks the other police
officer what's going on she says yes I'm
a police officer I'm guiding these
people and the guy kind of gives us a
stern shake of his head and gets into
his car and then drives away the reason
I tell this story is as you know on the
show
I am very Pro police officer I think law
enforcement does an amazing job overall
in the United States I love police
officers I defend police officers I'm
one of the biggest defenders of police
officers in America the reason I tell
this story is because one of the
narratives you hear a lot is that police
action when it's when it's bad action is
a result of racism something bad happens
to a black person it's automatically the
result of racism I am here to tell you
there are some police officers who are
just doof's I don't know if this guy's
name was
I know his badge number I wish I had it
okay but this police officer was a doof
he was a doof and it is important to
recognize that in every profession there
are dupes so when something bad happens
instead of immediately leaping to the
conclusion that it must be systemic
racism because police officers hate
black folks instead we might want to
think about the possibility that the
police officer is just a doof the kind
of doof would pull you over for
following another police officer I mean
frankly if you thought the police
officer in front of us was not a police
officer and was the civilian
impersonating a police officer he should
have given us a medal for making a
citizen's arrest against somebody who's
impersonating a police officer it was
just insane it was I mean it was really
funny our guys want one of the guys like
well should we just we were kind of
behind the other police car when he
pulled up to talk to the second officer
he's like should we pull up and I said
no just sit still okay this guy is super
jumpy I really don't want the headline
tomorrow to read Shapiro and security
shot to death by officer for following a
police officer to the airport in a
guided in a guidance would be a long
headline number one and number two
that's just that's a bad way to go so
that's my crazy story from this
particular trip okay other things that I
hate so CNN they hate racism over at CNN
unless it's a bunch of saying a bunch of
people saying kind of racist things
about Kanye West I think kind of like
racism so here was a full panel on CNN
in which all of the members of the panel
decided that it was totally okay to call
Kanye West a token Negro and suggests
that he is stupid because of his race
but now all of a sudden Kanye because
he's put on a maggot and he's an
attention like the president he's
all of a sudden now the the model
spokesperson he's the token negro of the
of the trump administration this is
ridiculous okay so that's great I'm just
I'm glad that we now know that folks on
the Left can call people token Negroes
and that's that's totally fine it is
amazing what the left can get away with
simply because they're members of the
political left there's a reason people
are not fond of this sort of rhetoric
it's gross okay we will be back here
tomorrow I will be back in Los Angeles
ensconced in my beautiful Studios I'm
like The Washington Post has my Studios
are very nice ensconced in our beautiful
studios and I will be taking your
questions in the mailbag so make sure to
subscribe now is a good time to do it
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro
show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex and Garo
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jess wah
Vera the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire for word publishing production
copyright Ford publishing 2018